on est plus à l'aise on respire mieux et
on est content des voyageurs qui se
sentent libres comme l'air les mesures
sanitaires sont tombées dans les gares
et les aéroports plus besoin de preuves
de vaccination fin des tests de
dépistage des mesures d'isolement et le
port du masque n'est plus obligatoire
bien que recommandé et on va conserver
les masques ma blonde
ça fait du bien pour les gens qui sont
pas vaccinés l'application devient
facultative elle était obligatoire
depuis février 2021 pour enregistrer
l'épreuve vaccinale des voyageurs et
faisait l'objet de nombreuses critiques
au cours des derniers mois la fin de
Harry Kane ça va être un grand plus que
dans un contexte de compétitivité
mondiale si on a le choix avec le moins
critère possible mais c'est sûr que pour
un visiteur peut-être qu'on était moins
attractif
près de la frontière Canada américaine
des commerçants attendaient ce retour à
la normale
de notre chiffre d'affaires
le fait que le côté américain Vienne et
aussi la mobilité même des Québécois qui
traversent qui reviennent puis pas chez
nous irait moins de paperasse et puis de
procédures alors je pense que ça va nous
aider on va commencer à voir plus les
effets maintenant bien que la covid-19
s'essouffle au pays le ministre fédéral
de la Santé Jean-Yves Duclos n'a pas
écarté l'idée que les mesures sanitaires
pour les voyageurs pourraient être
imposés de nouveau ici marie-abelle
Rochon Radio-Canada Montréal